lors du jour rappelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur alain marty
merci monsieur le président le groupe
est républicain s'associe bien sûr à
l'hommage que vous venez de rendre ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
les infirmiers les aides soignants les
personnels hospitaliers manifestent
aujourd'hui dans toute la france
ce mouvement de colère n'est pas à
prendre à la légère
je le redis ce mouvement de colère n'est
pas à prendre à la légère
il traduit l'exaspération de
professionnels dont l'action est
indispensable à notre système de santé à
la prise en charge des patients et plus
largement au maintien du lien social
ce que dénonce ces personnels de santé
épuisés stressés
ce sont les conditions de travail qui se
détériorent et la peur de ne plus être
en mesure d'assurer leurs missions
pourtant si importantes ceux qui
soignent le sentiment de mal faire leur
travail en raison des rythmes de travail
en raison des effectifs insuffisants et
des contraintes réglementaires
les infirmiers libéraux qui participent
eux aussi au mouvement sont bien souvent
les derniers professionnels accéder au
domicile et sont en cela le réceptacle
de la violence sociale dont souffre
notre pays
ces professionnels dénoncent également
une insécurité croissante dans
l'exercice de leur métier face à la
multiplication des agressions et des
incivilités
monsieur le premier ministre ces
personnels de santé sont les grands
oubliés de votre politique
ils vous le font savoir votre loi santé
s'est mise à dos l'ensemble des acteurs
de la santé avouer que la performance
est singulière et m'a répondu ah rien
aux attentes des infirmières et des
infirmiers dont j'ai pu comme praticien
hospitalier apprécié la compétence et le
dévouement
monsieur le premier ministre lors de la
loi sur le plfss
on nous a dit tout va bien
mais alors si tout va bien comment
expliquez-vous l'exaspération et la
colère des professionnels de santé
merci monsieur marty la parole est à
madame marisol touraine ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
marty je veux dire que je porte une
attention extrême à la situation de
l'hôpital public et je veux devant vous
comme je lé fais à plusieurs reprises
exprimé à tous les professionnels de
l'hôpital public à la fois ma
reconnaissance et la fierté que la
france puisse compter sur des
professionnels aussi remarquable au
quotidien je sais que les conditions de
travail sont parfois difficiles et que
des efforts importants ont été demandés
aux professionnels de santé à l'hôpital
public comme ailleurs
depuis un certain nombre d'années
je veux exprimer ma reconnaissance à ces
professionnels et leur dire que
j'entends leurs inquiétudes et leurs
préoccupations je les entends lorsque
dans le cadre de la loi dans le cadre de
décisions déjà prises
j'ai rétabli le service public
hospitalier qui avait été supprimé
j'entends la spécificité de l'hôpital
public
lorsque j'ai mis fin à la convergence
tarifaire entre le public et le privé et
j'ai entendu marquer la reconnaissance
envers les infirmiers lorsque des
revalorisations salariales allant
jusqu'à 3900 euros par an pour les
infirmières ont été engagées au cours
des années qui viennent de s'écouler
prolos et qui vont être prolongées par
des revalorisations supplémentaires mais
des réformes de fond ont été engagés qui
suppose que les personnels soient mieux
accompagnés et je suis certaine que
d'autres questions me donneront
l'occasion de répondre à ces points là
j'aurai l'occasion d'annoncer dans
quelques semaines
un plan d'accompagnement des
professionnels de santé en particulier à
l'hôpital public pour faire face aux
conditions de travail améliorées